à la gourmande là c'est vache c'est un
peu comme ces filles elles font partie
de la famille à la tête de son
exploitation depuis 1987 jean françois
guillemin est entré depuis 2014 dans une
spirale infernale
confronté à des difficultés financières
sa ferme familiale vit peut-être ses
dernières heures le 3 mai le tribunal a
décidé de mettre l'accent en liquidation
judiciaire
avec tout ce que ça comporte derrière
c'est à dire vente aux enchères s'il n'y
a pas de repreneur
on emmène les bêtes au marché au cadran
elles vont être vendus des clopinettes
pour garder le cachet et ça il en est
hors de question sans salaire depuis
trois ans jean-françois n'achète rien
d'autre que des aliments pour ses bêtes
et remplir son frigo comme il le peut
avec les produits de son potager bien
décidé à faire l'impossible pour sauver
sa centaine de vaches échappé à la
liquidation définitive de son
exploitation
le 5 juillet prochain il lance sa
cagnotte litchi après un reportage sur
une radio locale
sa collecte est un énorme succès qui
sensibilise dans toute la france sur le
sort de ses vaches une aide tombé du
ciel et déjà commencé à retirer 1000
euros pour acheter un peu de nourriture
aux bêtes pour essayer de les
complémenter puis qu'elle reprenne de
l'état puisqu'elle donne un peu plus de
lait là ça va nous servir acheter du
fuel pour pouvoir faire la récolte parce
que contrairement à la justice moi je
continue jusqu'au bout je continuerai je
vais récolter tout ce que je peux si ça
sert pas au bas ça servira au moins à
payer les gens à qui on a rendu à de
l'argent il faudrait à jean-françois
goumain recueillir jusqu'à cent
cinquante mille euros pour espérer
entrevoir le bout du tunnel
on n'en est pas encore là mais s'ils y
arrivent ici lui reste un peu d'argent
le paysan leur versera aux familles
d'agriculteurs dans le besoin et à
celles touchées par le suicide